While most of us are just trying to make it through 2020, historians and archivists are already thinking about what this era will look like in the rearview mirror. Historians of psychology are no exception. At the coming center for the history of psychology in Akron, Ohio, researchers curate a trove of materials that document more than a century of the discipline's history, including photos, films, the personal papers of hundreds of eminent psychologists, and even artifacts from some of the famous experiments you probably learned about if you took Psych 101. Right now, they're also thinking about how to preserve a record of our current times for future generations. Part of the coming center is the National Museum of Psychology.
虽然我们大多数人只是在努力熬过2020年，但历史学家和档案保管员已经在思考，当这个时代成为后视镜中的风景时会是什么样子。心理学历史学家也不例外。在俄亥俄州阿克伦即将落成的心理学历史中心，研究人员精心整理了大量资料，记录了该学科一个多世纪的历史，包括照片、电影、数百位杰出心理学家的个人手稿，甚至还有一些著名实验的实物，如果你上过“心理学101”课程，你可能对这些实验有所了解。现在，他们也在思考如何为后代保存我们这个时代的记录。即将落成的中心的一部分就是国家心理学博物馆。
Perhaps it never occurred to you that there even is such a place. And although it is closed to the public right now because of the COVID pandemic, its work continues and some of its exhibits are online. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Kathy Fay, a historian of psychology and director of the Cummings Center. She's here to tell us more about the center's collections, its public museum,
也许你从未想过世界上竟然会有这样一个地方。尽管它目前因新冠疫情而对公众关闭，但它的工作仍在继续，其中一些展览已经搬到了网上。欢迎收听“心理学热线”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是心理学历史学家、卡明斯中心主任凯茜·费伊（Kathy Fay）博士。她将为我们详细介绍中心的藏品、公共博物馆，
and the work that she and the other staff are doing to preserve psychology's past, even as they are documenting its present. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Fay. Thanks for having me. As I said, you're a historian of psychology, but right, now, one of your projects is very much focused on the present. You're working to document the changes that psychology and psychologists are going through in 2020. Can you tell our listeners what prompted you to start this project, what you're doing, and how it fits in with the center's
以及她和其他工作人员为了解心理学的过去、同时也在记录其现在所做的工作。欢迎来到“心理学热线”，费伊博士。谢谢邀请我。正如我所说，你是一位心理学历史学家，但现在，你的一个项目非常关注当下。你正在致力于记录2020年心理学和心理学家正在经历的变化。你能告诉我们的听众是什么促使你开始这个项目的吗？你正在做什么？它又是如何契合中心的
mission? Yeah, definitely. I'm really, you know, it's hard to continue to do historical work when you recognize that the moment you're living in right now really is a project for historians. So rather than focusing my attention on the past right now, like everybody else, I've been just so absorbed with all the changes that have happened for all of us in the present in 2020. So as I thought about that, I really began to think about all the changes that were happening in psychology and how we as historians of psychology might capture those changes. So for example, for the first time ever, the American Psychological Association's Convention was moved online. That's never happened before. Psychologists everywhere have scrambled, but also done a really fantastic job of
使命的？是的，当然。你知道，当你意识到你所生活的时代本身就是一个历史学家的项目时，要继续进行历史研究真的很困难。因此，我没有把注意力集中在过去，而是像其他人一样，完全沉浸在2020年我们所有人在现实中所经历的所有变化中。因此，在思考这个问题时，我真的开始思考心理学中正在发生的所有变化，以及我们作为心理学历史学家该如何捕捉这些变化。例如，美国心理学协会的年会历史上第一次转到了线上。这以前从未发生过。世界各地的心理学家都在争分夺秒，同时也做了一项非常出色的工作，
moving things like therapy and counseling online. You know, there's been such an increase in demand for psychological services through the pandemic and having, you know, being inside of the discipline. I just am watching psychologists rise to the occasion in ways that are just really unique and historic and things that we've never had to face before. So part of the impetus for this was really just seeing all the changes that were happening so quickly and recognizing as a historian that this is going to be an important moment in psychology. And if we don't have the materials necessary to tell this story. I think it would be a significant loss for the field. So that was sort of the first impetus. I was going to say, what are some of the items that you're collecting then to
比如将治疗和咨询搬到线上。你知道，在疫情期间，对心理学服务的需求激增，而且身处这个学科内部，我只是在看着心理学家们以一种真正独特、具有历史意义的方式迎接挑战，面对我们以前从未遇到过的事情。因此，这背后的动力一部分其实就是看到所有这些变化发生得如此之快，并作为一名历史学家认识到，这将是心理学中一个重要的时刻。如果我们没有讲述这个故事所需的材料，我认为这对该领域来说将是一个重大的损失。所以这算是最初的动力。我想说的是，那么你现在都在收集哪些物品来
document this time? Sure. So there's the central thing I'm doing right now is interviewing psychologists. So I'm looking for a diverse array of psychologists who are working inside of this pandemic in various kinds of ways and also living in it, right, as people, not just as psychologists, they're also living their regular lives. So I'm talking to these psychologists and using just the regular conferencing software that we've all gotten so comfortable with, Zoom and things like this, we're using that software to record our conversations. And those conversations will become part of the historical record of psychology. And we're really just focusing on, you know, a set of questions that ask them, you know, how psychology has changed during 2020 as both a result of the pandemic,
记录这个时期呢？当然。所以，我现在正在做的核心事情就是采访心理学家。我在寻找各种各样的心理学家，他们以各种方式在这次疫情中工作，同时也作为普通人生活在其中，不仅仅是作为心理学家，他们也在过着正常的生活。所以我在和这些心理学家交谈，并使用我们都已非常熟悉的常规会议软件——Zoom之类的软件来记录我们的对话。这些对话将成为心理学历史记录的一部分。我们真正关注的是，你知道的，提出一系列问题，问他们2020年心理学是如何发生变化的，这既是疫情的结果，
but also as a result of sort of the police brutality conversations that have been happening. I mean, I think that psychology has really changed in responding to that crisis as well. So we just sit down and we have a conversation about this and I ask them how their field of psychology has changed because of these things. And I also talk to them as people, right? So I asked them how they're doing through the pandemic and through this sort of crisis around social justice. And there's been some really wonderful conversations that have come out of it. And I really feel like 100 years from now historians are going to have a lot to work with because of it. Are people eager or reluctant to participate in these interviews?
也是关于警察暴力执法的讨论的结果。我的意思是，我认为心理学在应对这场危机时确实也发生了变化。所以我们坐下来，就此展开对话，我问他们，心理学领域因为这些事情发生了怎样的变化。我也以人的身份与他们交谈，对吧？所以我问他们在这场疫情以及这场围绕社会正义的危机中过得怎么样。由此产生了一些非常精彩的对话，我真的觉得100年后的历史学家会因此有很多素材可以使用。人们是渴望还是不愿意参加这些采访？
I think both. I think people are interested. But I think that one of the things that's interesting is that many people have said to me, oh, well, I'm not that important. They don't think that their voice is sort of important enough to be part of the historical record of psychology. And my response to that is always every single voice has a different story to tell. So a student who, you know, an undergraduate student in psychology, who is just starting to work in this online world, graduate students who are trying to begin their counseling or clinical psychology careers in this environment,
我认为两者兼有。我认为人们对此很感兴趣。但我觉得有趣的一点是，许多人对我说：“哦，我没那么重要。”他们认为自己的声音不够重要，不足以成为心理学历史记录的一部分。而我的回应总是：每一个声音都有不同的故事要讲。比如一个刚刚开始在这个网络世界中工作的本科生，比如试图在这种环境中开始他们的咨询或临床心理学职业生涯的研究生，
all the way up to, you know, the president of the American Psychological Association. Every one of those voices tells an important piece of the story for history. So this is what I keep trying to remind people as they sort of, their reluctance seems to be centered on the idea that their voice is not as important as somebody else's. So once we get past that, once I can convince people that they really do have important things to say around all of this and their own personal experience is very important, then they're excited. What kind of stories are you getting now? Yeah, you know, some of them are stories. So, for example, I spoke with a psychologist last week from Lebanon, who told me a lot about how they have had to shift the way in which they're training psychologists
一直到，你知道的，美国心理学协会的主席。每一个这样的声音都讲述了历史故事中重要的一部分。因此，这就是我一直试图提醒人们的，因为他们似乎不愿意参与，而这种不愿意似乎集中在“我的声音不如别人的声音重要”这种想法上。所以一旦我们克服了这一点，一旦我能说服人们，他们确实有重要的事情要讲，围绕这一切以及他们自己的个人经历非常重要，那么他们就会感到兴奋。你现在收到了什么样的故事？是的，你知道，其中一些是这样的故事。例如，上周我采访了一位来自黎巴嫩的心理学家，他告诉我很多关于他们如何不得不改变培训心理学家的方式的情况，
because there's such a high demand for mental health care in Lebanon because of the pandemic as well as several other events that have occurred in Lebanon. Sure, they had that huge explosion that really impacted. the Lebanese. Exactly. We talked a lot about the warehouse explosion and how the sort of the increase in demand, both for those who are grieving, as well as those who were just near the blast when it happened. So there was a lot of demand for mental health care along with, you know, the pandemic and sort of the economic crisis that is going on as well. And so they've had to really think on their feet and start to train students to be providers. And this will lead to probably permanent changes in the way
因为在黎巴嫩，由于疫情以及黎巴嫩发生的其他几起事件，对心理健康护理的需求非常高。当然，他们遭遇了那场对黎巴嫩人民产生巨大影响的巨大爆炸。正是如此。我们深入探讨了仓库爆炸事件，以及哀悼者和爆炸发生时就在附近的人对心理健康护理需求的增加。因此，除了疫情和正在发生的经济危机之外，对心理健康护理的需求非常大。因此，他们不得不随机应变，开始培训学生成为服务提供者。这可能会导致他们提供心理健康护理服务的方式以及培训学生的方式发生永久性的改变。因此，这类职业故事非常重要。它们是国际化的，对吧？所以我们可以开始了解全球正在发生的事情。但也有，你知道的，个人故事对我也很有吸引力。所以，我采访了一位心理学家，她跟我交谈时谈到，她是一位非裔美国女性，我们讨论了乔治·弗洛伊德（George Floyd）之被害以及围绕该事件发生的所有事情。她向我讲述了在这种环境下抚养一个年轻黑人男孩是什么感觉，在她的社区周围到处都是抗议活动以及所有这些事情发生时，与他交谈并陪伴他散步是什么感觉。因此，我认为这些故事也非常非常重要和有趣。是的，这些故事其实任何一位黑人母亲都可以
that they deliver mental health care services in the way that they train students. So these professional kinds of stories are really important. They're, and they're international, right? So we can start to get a sense of what's happening around the globe. But there's also, you know, the personal stories are really interesting to me as well. So I spoke with one psychologist who talked to me about, She's an African-American woman, and we were talking about the killing of George Floyd and sort of all of the things that have happened around that. And she talked to me about what it's like to raise a young black son in this environment and what it's like to sort of talk with him and walk with him as protests go on all around her in her neighborhood and all of these kinds of things. So those stories are also, I think, really, really important and interesting. Yeah, and those are stories that really any black mother can.
讲给你听，你不仅仅是一位心理学家，尽管我想你会得到一个稍微不同的视角。是的，实际上，我想也许你会得到一个稍微不同的视角，但归根结底，这也是我热爱这个项目的原因之一，那就是我们看到心理学家作为心理学家的那一面，但我们也能看到他们作为普通人的那一面——他们正努力在对每个人来说都非常困难的一年中寻找出路。你心中有一个终点吗？我们根本不知道这种围绕疫情的疯狂状态何时会停止。所以，你就会一直做下去，直到有人宣布紧急状态已经过去，我们有了疫苗？这是一个极好的问题。
probably tell you're not just a psychologist, although you'd get a slightly different perspective, I would think. Yeah, I actually, I think maybe you get a little bit of a different perspective, but I think at the end of the day, it's one of the things that I love about this project is that we see psychologists as psychologists, but we also get to see them as people trying to make their way through what has been for everybody a really difficult year. Do you have an end point in mind? We have no idea when this whole craziness around the pandemic will stop. So do you just keep going until somebody says the emergency is passed and we have a vaccine? That's an excellent question.
我没有设定终点。我有点随性地表示，我会一直收集采访到今年年底，这只是因为在某个时候我必须转向其他项目，就像我们所有人一样。但实际上，这是我想继续使用的一种原型，因为我把它设计成了一个公民科学项目。不是只有我一个人在做采访。一旦我采访了某个人，我就会把问题清单交给他，并鼓励他们想出一个可能是这个项目的好人选的人。那可能是他们的导师之一。可能是他们职业生涯早期认识的人。然后他们
I don't have an end point. I sort of arbitrarily have said I'll continue to collect interviews until the end of the year, only because at some point I have to move on to other projects, as we all do. But really, it's one of these things that it's a prototype I kind of want to keep using because I've set it up as kind of a citizen science project. I'm not the only one doing the interviews. Once I interview somebody, I give them the question set, and I encourage them to think up somebody who might be a good voice for this project. So that might be one of their mentors. It might be somebody that they knew earlier in their career. And then they can
基本上可以充当采访者并收集采访。我喜欢这样，因为这样就不是由我来决定谁的声音重要，对吧？每个人都可以做出这样的选择，我认为这是这个项目非常独特的一部分。是的，这听起来有点像“故事核心”（StoryCorps）模式，可能会非常有趣，而且他们只是普通人在讲述彼此的故事。是的，我以前没想过。但是，是的，它确实很像StoryCorps，因为它不是，你知道的，它不像历史学家通常会做的那种完整的口述历史采访，因为如果我们做完整的采访，我们根本没有时间收集那么多的故事。所以我们的目标其实是广度而不是深度。
basically serve as the interview and collect interviews as well. And I like that because then I'm not the one deciding whose voice is important, right? Everybody gets to sort of make those choices, which I think is a really unique part of this project. Yeah, it sounds a little like the story core model, which can be extremely interesting, and they're just regular people telling stories about each other. Yeah, I hadn't thought of it. But yeah, and it is very much like story core in that it's not, you know, it's not a full oral history interview the way that a historian would normally do because we simply don't have the time to gather as many stories as we would if we were doing full interviews. So the goal really is breadth rather than depth.
但我感到惊奇的是，即使在短短20分钟的讨论中，我们也能探讨得相当深，这真的太棒了。让我们花几分钟聊聊中心本身。正如我刚才所说，它包含一个档案馆和一个博物馆。你能做个概述，简单介绍一下这两者，以及它们的异同吗？当然可以。是的，心理学历史中心自1965年成立以来就一直存在，我们基本上是一个研究机构，负责收集、维护
But I've been surprised that even in a short 20-minute discussion, we get pretty deep, which I which is really wonderful. Let's talk about the center itself for a few minutes. As I said earlier, it encompasses an archive and a museum. Can you give an overview, tell a little bit about each and how they're different and the same? Sure. Yeah, so the Center for the History of Psychology, we've been around since 1965, and we are basically a research institution that collects, cares for,
和分享心理学的历史记录。我认为我们真的是世界上唯一一个藏品规模如此之大，且几乎专门致力于收集心理学历史记录的档案馆和博物馆。因此，对于那些没有参观过档案馆的人来说，你会发现那里的东西种类包括
and shares the historical record of psychology. I think we are really the only archives is a museum in the world that has a collection quite this large and that devotes itself pretty much solely to collecting the historical record of psychology. So for those who haven't visited an archive, the kinds of things you're going to find there
信件，即心理学家之间的书信、个人日记、委员会会议的会议记录，任何未出版的、你在图书馆里找不到的东西，这就是你会在我们的藏品中找到的。例如，许多人熟悉亚伯拉罕·马斯洛（Abraham Maslow）和需求层次理论。我们藏品中的其中一件东西就是亚伯拉罕·马斯洛非常年轻时的个人日记。所以这是你在图书馆里找不到的，你只能
are correspondence, so letters between psychologists, personal diaries, meeting minutes from committee meetings, anything that isn't sort of published that you could find in a library, that's what you're going to find in our conference. collections. So for example, many people are familiar with Abraham Maslow and the hierarchy of needs. One of the things we have in our collection is Abraham Maslow's personal diaries from the time he was quite young. So something you're not going to find in a library, you're only going to find
在我们的档案馆里找到。因此，我们的核心功能其实就是档案馆。我们收集并保存心理学的历史记录。但是，随着我们的成长和发展，我们发现公众对我们保存在档案馆中的所有材料非常感兴趣，我们发现自己会带领人们参观这个空间。因此，在2018年，我们推出了一个公共博物馆，这就是国家心理学博物馆，我们在那里与公众分享我们的藏品。如果我们去博物馆参观，可能会看到哪些最著名和最声名狼藉的物品呢？所以，我们在博物馆里最著名的物品可能就是斯坦福监狱实验（Stanford Prison Experiment）的材料。那是20世纪60年代一个非常著名的研究，当时大学生被分配扮演警卫和囚犯的角色，然后在几天的时间里观察他们的行为。
in our archives. So our central function really is as the archives. We collect and preserve the historical record of psychology. But as we kind of grew and developed, we discovered that the public was very interested in all of the materials that we held in the archives and we'd find ourselves touring people through the space. So in 2018, we launched a public museum and this is the National Museum of Psychology where we share our collections with the public. What are some of the most famous and infamous objects that we might see if we go to the museum? So probably our most famous objects in the museum are the materials from the Stanford Prison Experience. The very famous study in the 1960s where college students were assigned roles of guards and prisoners, and then their behavior was observed over the course of a few days.
这是一个许多人熟悉的实验。所以我们有那个研究中原始的监狱门、警卫制服、囚犯制服。我们还有藏品中的另一个著名物品——斯坦利·米尔格拉姆（Stanley Milgram）服从性研究中的模拟电击发生器。这是另一个许多人熟悉的实验，它探讨了为什么我们服从处于权威地位的人。所以这些可能是我们最受欢迎的两件物品。我藏品中最喜欢的物品是一个叫做“心理图表仪”（psychograph）的东西。这是一种基于一种名为颅相学（phrenology）的旧伪科学的机器。颅相学的基础是这样一种观念：你可以通过触摸一个人头部的肿块，利用头骨的轮廓来解读他们的性格。颅相学
And this is a study that many people are familiar with. So we have the original prison door from that study, the guard uniform, the prisoner uniforms. We also have the other famous object in our collections is the simulated shock generator from Stanley Milgram's studies of obesity. obedience. Another study that many people are familiar with that looked at why we obey people who are in positions of authority. So these are probably our two most popular items. My favorite item in our collections is something called a psychograph. And this is a machine that was based on an old pseudoscience called phrenology. Phrenology was based on the notion that you could sort of feel the bumps on someone's head and using the contours of the skull, you could read their personality. And phrenology
在19世纪早期、整个19世纪甚至在美国世纪之交时非常非常受欢迎，这些巡回颅相学家会在全国各地四处奔走，你付给他们一小笔费用，他们就会帮你读头。他们会利用这个解读来告诉你应该从事什么职业。你应该成为一名医生吗？你应该成为一名律师吗？诸如此类。因此，在20世纪30年代，一对兄弟决定从颅相学中赚取更多的钱，他们创造了一种基本上是自动化的颅相学机器。所以你可以把一些钱投入机器中。你坐在椅子上，一个小斗子会从你的头上落下来。它会读取你的头部，并提供一份你的性格打印件和一些职业指导。它还能运转吗？
was very, very popular in the early, throughout the 1800s and even around the turn of the century in the United States, these traveling phrenologists would sort of go around the country and you'd give them a small fee and they would read your head. And they'd use that reading to tell you what you should become. Should you be a doctor? Should you be a lawyer? So on, so forth. So the site a graph, a couple of brothers in the 1930s decided to make more money off of phrenology, and they created basically an automated phrenology machine. So you could put some money into the machine. You sit down on a chair, a little bucket comes down over your head. It reads your head and provides a printout of your personality and some career guidance. Does it still function?
你用过吗？它确实还能完全运转，你知道吗？我们认为世界上只剩下大约七台了，因为大多数都在一次仓库火灾中被毁了。所以它确实还能完全工作。我们不再使用它了，因为它们太稀有了，所以我们通常不操作它。但是，是的，它仍然可以工作，并且在博物馆里展出。这听起来像是杂耍摊上的东西，你把钱投进去，就会得到一张写着你命运的小纸条。是的，你这么说真好笑。它实际上曾一度在戴维·莱特曼（David Letterman）的节目中亮相。游客们似乎对哪些东西最感兴趣？是的，看到
Have you used it? It does still completely function, you know? And we think there's only about seven of them left in the world because most of them were destroyed in a warehouse fire. So it does still completely work. We don't use it anymore because they're so rare, so we don't usually operate it. But yeah, it's still works and it's on display in the museum. It sounds like something from a side show where you put your money in and you get a little slip with your fortune. Yeah, that's funny you say it. It was actually featured once on the David Letterman show. What are the things that visitors seem most interested in? Yeah, it's been wonderful to see.
公众对博物馆有多么喜爱，这真是太棒了。我想他们之所以对它和心理学这么感兴趣，是因为心理学向我们讲述了太多关于我们自己和我们世界的事情。有时我们甚至没有意识到，但心理学每天都在我们身边。在我们购买的产品中，在技术中，心理学研究都倾注在其中。这很有趣。我想公众喜欢了解这一点，了解他们的世界是如何被心理学塑造的。例如，我们有一个展览，探讨了手机键盘的现代设计实际上是由一位心理学家创造的。当然。
how much the public enjoys the museum. And I think they're so interested in it and in psychology, because, you know, psychology tells us so much about ourselves and our world. And sometimes we don't even realize it, but psychology is around us every single day. In the products we buy, in the technology, we use psychological work went into all of that. And it's interesting. I think the public enjoys learning about that, the way that their world has been shaped by psychology. So for example, we have an exhibit that explores how the modern design of your cell phone keypad was actually created by a psychologist. Of course. Yeah. So in the nine, and this happened way back in the 1950s. So a psychologist was hired by the Bell telephone company to try to,
是的。所以，在——这发生在20世纪50年代。当时，贝尔电话公司（Bell Telephone Company）雇佣了一位心理学家来尝试，你知道的，在那个时候，电话呼叫都是由话务员引导的，他们需要快速完成。因此，贝尔雇佣了一位心理学家来弄清楚哪种数字键盘布局会导致最少的错误，并允许话务员以尽可能快的速度转接这些电话。因此，如果你看看今天手机上的数字键盘，那就是心理学家在20世纪50年代确定的实际上会导致最少错误的数字键盘。所以你可以，你可以感谢一位心理学家让你能如此轻松地使用手机上的数字键盘。因此，我认为公众对这类故事真的很感兴趣，现在他们可以回到自己的世界中，看到所有这些他们每天都在使用和接触的东西，并看到心理学研究是如何融入其中的。是的，我们喜欢把后车窗的高位刹车灯说成是心理学家发明的，而人们完全不知道心理学家会在人因工程学（human factors）领域做这种工作。
you know, at this point, telephone calls were all directed by telephone operators and they needed to do it quickly. So Bell hired a psychologist to figure out which number, number pad layout would lead to the least amount of errors and would allow telephone operators to relay those calls as quickly as possible. So if you look at your number pad on your cell phone today, that's the number pad that psychologists determined in the 1950s actually led to the least amount of errors. So you can, you can thank a psychologist for your ease of using the number keypad on your cell phone. So I think that the public is really interested in these kinds of stories where now they can kind of go back out into their world and see all these things that they sort of use and engage with every day and see how psychological work went into that. Yeah, we like to talk about the breaklight in the rear window as something that was invented by psychologists and people have no idea that psychologists do that work in the area of human factors.
是的，绝对是这样。这是，你知道的，我们在推出博物馆时有几个目标，其中之一就是真正鼓励人们理解，心理学有很多种，心理学家也有很多类型，因为，你知道的，人们往往对临床和咨询心理学有很多了解。所以人们把心理学与治疗联系在一起，这绝对是心理学核心功能之一。但心理学家做各种各样的事情。我真的认为人们走出我们的博物馆时会意识到这一点是千真万确的。我们将心理学视为一门科学，也就是一种基础实验室科学。我们将它视为在企业、工作场所、诊所和医院等应用环境中的一种职业。我们也将心理学视为社会变革的推动者——也就是心理学研究如何引领我们的社会世界和公共政策发生重大变化，诸如此类的事情。你是如何为档案馆和博物馆获取物品的，以及你是如何决定什么值得保存的？
Yes, definitely. This is, you know, we had a few goals when we launched the museum, and one of them was to really encourage people to understand that there are many kinds of psychologies and many types of psychologists because, you know, there's, there tends to be a lot of knowledge of clinical and counseling psychology. So people associate psychology with therapy, and that's definitely one of the central functions of psychology. But psychologists do all. kinds of things. And I really do think that people walk out of our museum realizing that that's true. We look at psychology as a science, so sort of a basic laboratory science. We look at it as a profession in applied kinds of settings like businesses and workplaces and clinics and hospitals. And we also look at psychology as an agent of social change. So the way that psychological research has led to significant changes in our social world in our public policies, these kinds of things. How do you acquire objects for the archives and for the museum, and how do you
我们藏品中的所有材料都是捐赠的，我们现在相对比较知名，所以通常发生的情况是，当人们开始考虑退休时，如果他们有自己认为档案馆会感兴趣的材料，就会联系我们。要么就是当一个人去世后，他们的伴侣、孩子或类似的人会联系我们并告知我们。然后我们会与这些人讨论他们究竟拥有什么。我们有藏品政策来帮助我们做出关于收录什么和不收录什么的决定。但这并不是一个容易的决定。
decide what's worth saving? All of the materials in our collections are donated, and we're relatively well-known now, so it generally happens that when people are starting to think about retiring, they'll contact us if they have material that they think is of interest to the archives. Either that or once a person passes their significant other or their children or something along those lines, they will contact us and let us know. And then we have a discussion with those people about what exactly it is they have. And we have collections policies that help us make decisions about what to include and what not to include. But it isn't an easy decision.
档案馆总是面临一个重大的问题，那就是你的空间是有限的，但你的藏品将永远在增长。所以我们面临这个问题，我们确实会仔细考虑我们接受什么，但我们随时愿意就可获得的材料进行交流。很多档案材料都数字化了吗？是也不是。纸质材料，我们往往不会进行那么多的数字化，因为实际上纸张可以保存很长时间。因此，当涉及到数字化材料时，我们的优先事项确实集中在媒体上。所以我们拥有大量的静态图像、照片、底片幻灯片。我们拥有大约12,000盘电影胶片的大型藏品。
Archives are always faced with one significant problem, which is that your space is limited, but your collections will always be growing. So we face this issue, and we do think carefully about what we accept, but we're always open to having a conversation about materials that are available. Is a lot of the archival material digitized? Yes and no. The paper-based material, we tend not to digitize quite so much, because actually paper lasts a very long time. So our priorities when it comes to digitizing material are really centered on media. So we have a large collection of still images, photographs, negative slides. We have a large collection about 12,000 reels of film.
还有许多物品，我想目前我们已经收集了大约1,400件来自心理学历史的文物。因此，我们将精力集中在数字化媒体和保护文物上。纸质材料——大多数人惊讶地发现，这可能是图书馆和档案馆拥有的最稳定的材料。藏品有多大？有多少在公开展示？藏品大约有，我可以说，目前有4,000线性英尺。所以如果你能想象一下，一个线性英尺大约是一个标准搬家箱的大小，比如一个银行纸箱。所以如果你能想象大约4,000个这样的箱子堆叠在一起，那大约就是我们藏品的大小。就实际展出的内容而言，我可以说该藏品的1%正在博物馆展出。
And a number of objects as well, I think at this point we're up to about 1,400 artifacts from the history of psychology. And so we focus our efforts on digitizing the media and preserving the artifacts. Paper-based materials are – most people are surprised to learn are probably the most stable kinds of materials. the libraries and archives hold. How big is the collection and how much is on public display? The collection is approximately, I would say, 4,000 linear feet at this point. So if you can imagine, a linear foot is about the size of a standard moving box, like a banker's box. So if you can imagine about 4,000 of those stacked up together, that's approximately the size of our collections. In terms of what's actually available on display, I would say 1% of that collection is on display in the museum.
我们博物馆里确实有一个轮换展厅，我们会尽可能频繁地更换展览。通常我们试图以某种方式将它与时事联系起来，这样人们可以同时与历史和现实互动。但总的来说，我想我们大概有1%的藏品在展出。对于拥有大量藏品的绝大多数博物馆来说，这都是相当标准的。对我们来说，我们认为这其实相当棒。这只意味着我们有比我们可能永远没有时间和空间分享的更多的故事要讲。你与史密森尼学会（Smithsonian）有隶属关系，对吧？这具体意味着什么？
We do have a rotating gallery in the museum where we switch out the exhibit as frequently as possible. Usually we try to tie that to current events in some way so that people can interact with history and the present at the same time. But for the most part, I would say we've got probably 1%. And that's pretty standard for most museums with large collections. And for us, we consider that to be actually quite wonderful. It just means we have more stories to tell than we could possibly ever have time or space to share. And you have an affiliation with the Smithsonian, right? What does that mean exactly?
是的，我们实际上是该国第一个成为史密森尼附属机构的档案馆。其他机构也纷纷效仿。但我们在2002年成为了史密森尼的附属机构。这是一个相当严格的申请过程。所以我们很高兴能被该项目接受。这基本上意味着史密森尼可以向我们借用物品。我们可以从任何史密森尼博物馆的藏品中借用物品。因此，国家博物馆、美国历史博物馆，我们可以从他们任何博物馆的藏品中借用。
Yeah, so we were actually the first archives in the country to become a Smithsonian affiliate. Others have followed suit. But we became a Smithsonian affiliate in 2002. It's quite a rigorous application process. So we were quite pleased to be accepted into the program. And basically what it means is that the Smithsonian can borrow objects from us. We can borrow objects from any of the Smithsonian museums from their collections. So the National Museum, the American History Museum, any of their museums we can borrow from their collections.
而且他们的教育工作者会来参加活动并进行演讲。他们将参与我们的节目，我们也参与他们的节目。所以这是一个非常棒的伙伴关系。我们参加史密森尼博物馆日（Smithsonian Museum Day），向公众免费开放我们的博物馆大门。我们参加他们的会议。这对我们来说真的非常非常富有成效。我认为这有助于我们为公众和观众带来更好、更丰富的内容。你是如何选择最终进入轮换展览的内容的？
And also their educators will come and speak at events. They'll take part in our programs and we take part in theirs. So it's been a really wonderful partnership. We participate in Smithsonian Museum Day, which opens the doors to our museum for free to the public. We participate in their conferences. It's been really, really fruitful for us. And I think it helps us to bring better and more content to our public and our audiences. How do you choose what ends up in your rotating exhibits?
有什么委员会与你合作吗？我们有一个内部委员会负责安排展览日程。但总的来说，我们尽量不对进入该展厅的内容做过多的限制。原因在于，我们真的很想反映现实中正在发生的事情。例如，有些人可能不知道。我们的博物馆位于俄亥俄州阿克伦。有些人可能不知道。但匿名戒酒互助会（Alcoholics Anonymous）就是在俄亥俄州阿克伦创立的。
Is there some committee who works with you? We have an internal committee that works on sort of scheduling exhibits. But for the most part, we try not to be too strict about what's going to go in that gallery. And the reason being, we really do like to reflect what's happening in the present. So, for example, some people may not know. So our museum is located in Akron, Ohio. And some people may not know. But Alcoholics Anonymous was founded in Akron, Ohio.
所以我们有点像在查看日历并说，好吧，如果那个创立纪念日即将来临，我们要成为其中的一部分。我们想做一个关于戒酒互助会及其历史以及与心理学联系的展览。同样，在9·11前后，我们做了一个关于9·11的临时展览。所以我们喜欢对那个展厅空间保持开放和灵活，并随时关注心理学和世界上正在发生的事情，从而能够随机应变，推出重要且适时的展览。好吧，既然我们的听众现在不能去参观，也许你能告诉我们展厅里目前有什么？
So we sort of look ahead at the calendar and say, well, if the anniversary of that founding is coming on, we want to be a part of that. we want to create an exhibit on on AA and its history and its connections to psychology. Similarly, around 9-11, we did a temporary exhibit on 9-11. So we like to sort of be open and flexible with that gallery space and to sort of keep our ear to what's happening in psychology and what's happening in the world and sort of be able to think on our feet and put exhibits up that are going to matter and be timely. Well, since our listeners can't go to see right now, maybe you could Tell us what's in the gallery at the moment?
嗯，实际上，在那个展厅里，我们正处于中途。当我们闭馆时，我们正忙于创建一个展览，一个非常有趣的展览，我希望它很快就会展出，这是一个关于创造力的展览，这对心理学家来说非常有趣，我想对每个人来说也非常有趣。那么，什么是创造力？随着时间的推移，心理学家是如何定义这一概念的？我们是如何创建创造力测试的？所以那个展览的特色之一是举办了大量不同的测试，参观者实际上可以参加这些测试来探索他们自己的创造力。我们在那个展览中有心理学家的创意作品。所以我们的档案馆里有许多由心理学家创作的诗歌、短篇小说甚至几部电影。
Well, actually, in that gallery, we were in the midst. When we shut down, we were in the midst of creating an exhibit, a really interesting exhibit that I'm hoping will go up soon, which is an exhibit on creativity, something that's very interesting to psychologists, and I think very interesting to everybody. So what is creativity? How have psychologists defined that over time? How have we created tests of creativity? So one of the things that is featured in that exhibit are a whole bunch of different tests that visitors could actually take to explore their own creative talent. We have creative works by psychologists in that exhibit. So we have in our archives a number of poems and short stories and even a few films that were made by psychologists.
因此，我们既突出了心理学家的创造性工作，也突出了心理学家为理解创造力和理解富有创造力的个人所做的工作。所以这就是我希望我们能够推出的展览。我们正计划今年秋天以某种形式重新开馆。所以希望届时可以进行参观。我们还有一个非常棒的网站，我们正致力于在上面推出一些虚拟展览。所以目前我们正在做，我们刚刚推出了一个关于LGBTQ+群体及其与心理学历史的关系以及与心理学的当代关系的虚拟展览。所以我们也在努力让自己更容易被世界各地的所有人接触到。你的大部分参观者都是心理学家吗？他们是谁？他们来自哪里？
So we highlight the creative work of psychologists as well as the work that psychologists have done to understand creativity and to understand creative individuals. So that's the exhibit that I hope we'll be able to launch. We are planning on opening again in some capacity this fall. So hopefully that will be available for viewing. We also have a pretty great website and we're working on getting some virtual exhibits up there. So currently we're doing, we just launched a virtual exhibit on LGBTQ plus communities and their relationship with the history of psychology and contemporary relationship with psychology. So we're also working to. make ourselves more available to everybody around the world. Are most of your visitors psychologists? Who are they? Where do they come from? We definitely have a number of psychologists who come through, I would say, psychologists and more so even psychology students. So everything from high school psychology classes, we get a lot of tour groups through
我们确实接待了许多来访的心理学家，我想说，心理学家甚至更多的还有心理学学生。所以从高中心理学班级开始，我们接待了许多旅游团，这些团甚至远道从佛罗里达州赶来，一直到在该领域大有建树的人士。但非常有趣的是，除了心理学家和心理学学生，我们也接待了很多普通公众。我想这其实是一个口碑的问题。而且我们已经登上了猫途鹰（TripAdvisor）和其中一些其他旅游网站，这也有所帮助。
that have come to us from as far as Florida, all the way through to people who are well established in the field. But it's quite interesting because along with psychologists and psychology students, we also just get a lot of the general public in. And I think that's really been a matter of word of mouth. And we've made it onto TripAdvisor and some of these other travel sites, which helps as well. Yeah. And that's where I kind of look at to sort of understand what people are getting out of the museum. And really, it seems that the general public is coming because they're very interested in learning more about themselves. They can take tests. They can take intelligence tests. They can sort of learn about how advertising uses psychology and sort of be more aware of all of these
是的。这就是我用来了解人们从博物馆中获得什么的地方。真的，看起来普通公众来这里是因为他们对了解自己非常感兴趣。他们可以参加测试。他们可以参加智力测试。他们可以了解广告是如何利用心理学的，并对所有这些事情有更多的认识。
kinds of things. So we do get a lot of the general public in. But I would say the majority is probably students, people who are studying to become psychologists. Now, I know you've written about the need to diversify the voices in psychology's historical record. Can you talk about why that's important and how you're doing that? Yeah, I think it's so important right now to think about diversity and the historical record. And this is one of the reasons I launched this oral history project, and I'm doing it very purposefully with diversity in mind. I think that one of the reasons it's so important to have a diverse historical record is because it not only defines what psychology has been, but it defines what psychology can be. So when someone who is thinking,
所以我们确实接待了很多普通公众。但我想说，大多数可能还是学生，那些正在学习成为心理学家的人。现在，我知道你曾写过关于需要使心理学历史记录中的声音多样化的文章。你能谈谈为什么这很重要以及你是如何做到的吗？是的，我认为现在考虑多样性和历史记录是如此重要。这也是我发起这个口述历史项目的原因之一，我在做这件事时非常有目的地考虑到了多样性。我认为拥有一个多元化的历史记录之所以如此重要，原因之一在于它不仅定义了心理学曾经是什么，它还定义了心理学可以成为什么。因此，当一个正在考虑
about becoming a psychologist looks at who has historically been a psychologist. I think that impacts their decision on whether or not to go into the field. So if you look at psychology and you only see white faces or you only see male faces, I think it discourages diversity in the future of the field. So this is one of the reasons I'm really interested in diversifying the historical record and creating exhibits that that showcase the diversity of psychology because I think it will encourage a more diverse future for psychology. I also think it's just really important to understand all the contributions that diverse voices and faces and people have made to the discipline. They've made significant contributions and this is something that often goes unrecognized. You know, I always ask,
成为心理学家的人看到谁历史上曾是心理学家时。我认为这会影响他们是否决定进入该领域的决定。因此，如果你看看心理学，只看到白人的面孔或只看到男性的面孔，我认为这会阻碍该领域未来的多样性。因此，这就是为什么我对使历史记录多样化并创建展示心理学多样性的展览如此感兴趣的原因，因为我认为这将鼓励心理学拥有一个更加多元化的未来。我也认为，理解多元化的声音、面孔和人为该学科做出的所有贡献真的非常重要。他们做出了重大的贡献，而这往往是未被认识到的。你知道，我总是问，
I teach history of psychology and I always ask my students, how many, uh, how many women of color they can name in the history of psychology. And often it's very few, if any. And I would like to change that. I think it's important to understand that there were just so many amazing women who shaped the field. And they shaped it in ways that are different, I think, from mainstream voices and faces. So one of the things I've found by doing this kind of work is that, For example, African-American women in the history of psychology have done so much important work in terms of social justice and community outreach. So they're often left out of stories because our stories focus so commonly on the history of experimental, laboratory, scientific psychology. Whereas women of color in the history of psychology have done so much significant work in terms of the helping professions, in terms of applied kinds of psychology.
我教授心理学史，我总是问我的学生，他们能在心理学历史上说出多少，呃，多少有色人种女性的名字。通常非常少，如果有的话。我想改变这一点。我认为重要的是要理解，有如此多的杰出女性塑造了这一领域。我认为她们塑造它的方式与主流声音和面孔不同。因此，通过做这种类型的工作，我发现的一件事是，例如，心理学历史上的非裔美国女性在社会公正和社区外展方面做了如此多重要的工作。因此，她们经常被排除在故事之外，因为我们的故事通常集中在实验、实验室、科学心理学的历史。而心理学历史上的有色人种女性在帮助行业方面、在应用心理学方面、
in terms of working as psychologists in their community. So there's this entire branch of psychology that gets missed when we leave out these diverse kinds of voices. So I'm really hopeful that we can change that. And that historians, 100 years from now, will have a better archival record to work with when they want to tell those stories. And that realization, I think, led to the creation of the I. I am psyched traveling exhibition that you worked on with APA. I know I've seen that. It's been in our building. Do you want to talk about that for a moment?
在作为心理学家在社区中工作方面，做了如此多重大的工作。因此，当我们遗漏这些多样化的声音时，心理学的这整个分支就被遗漏了。所以我真的希望我们能改变这一点。而且100年后的历史学家在想要讲述这些故事时，将拥有更好的档案记录。而且这种认识，我认为，促成了你与APA合作创作的“我是心理学”（I Am Psyched）巡回展览。我知道我见过那个展览。它曾在我们的建筑里展出过。你想谈谈那个吗？
Yeah, the I Am Psyched exhibit is one of the most wonderful things I have been a part of in my career. It was launched in 2016 as part of the Smithsonian Institution's Museum Day, which they hold every year. So I worked with the American Psychological Association with Dr. Sherry Miles Cohen, as well as Dr. Alexander Rutherford, who runs a project called Psychology's Feminist Voices. And together we decided to create a traveling exhibit that could go from site to site that would showcase women of color in the history of psychology. And we worked with archival materials from our collections and created this exhibit that shared women of color in psychology all the way from the early 1900s to the first African-American woman to get a PhD in psychology all the way through to the present looking at, for example, the work of Jennifer Eberhardt, who has done such groundbaking work on stereotyping and racial prejudice. And this exhibit was so successful. I was expecting it to be great, and I was expecting it to gain some ground. But really, I mean, at this point, it's traveled, I think, to more than 40
是的，“I Am Psyched”展览是我职业生涯中参与过的最棒的事情之一。它于2016年启动，作为史密森尼学会每年举办的博物馆日的一部分。所以我与美国心理学协会的雪莉·迈尔斯·科恩（Sherry Miles Cohen）博士，以及负责一个名为“心理学的女性主义声音”（Psychology's Feminist Voices）项目的亚历山大·卢瑟福（Alexander Rutherford）博士合作。我们共同决定创建一个可以从一个地方巡展到另一个地方的巡回展览，展示心理学历史上的有色人种女性。我们使用了来自我们藏品的档案材料，并创建了这个展览，分享了从20世纪初到获得心理学博士学位的第一个非裔美国女性，一直到现在的心理学有色人种女性，例如，着眼于詹妮弗·埃伯哈特（Jennifer Eberhardt）的工作，她在刻板印象和种族偏见方面做了如此开创性的工作。这个展览非常成功。我原本期望它会很棒，并且我期望它能取得一些进展。但真的，我的意思是，到目前为止，它已经巡展了，我想，超过40个
sites across the country, all the way from the East Coast to the West Coast. But the more exciting thing about it is that as the exhibit goes up in any given site, and we hosted it here at the Cunning Center, people often will also have an event around it, so they'll get together a panel of speakers. They'll have a party. They'll get students to serve as docents for the exhibit. And because of this, it just brings all these people together in this very powerful celebratory way to share and think about and talk about women of color in psychology's past and present. And it's been wonderful. I think that it has created change already. And I think that moving forward, we can continue to sort of mobilize that and help young girls and young women of
全国各地都设有展览点，从东海岸一直延伸到西海岸。但更令人兴奋的是，当展览在任何一个地方举办时——我们自己就在坎宁中心举办过——人们通常也会围绕它举办各种活动，比如组织专家小组座谈会、举办派对、让学生担任展览的讲解员。正因为如此，它以一种非常有感染力的庆祝方式，将所有人凝聚在一起，去分享、思考和讨论有色女性在心理学过去与现在中的角色。这真的是一段美好的经历。我认为它已经带来了改变。而且我认为，展望未来，我们可以继续以某种方式调动这种力量，帮助有色人种
color see psychology as a space for them as a welcoming space and as a space where they can do the kinds of things they want and create change if that's what they're interested in. Are there plans right now to get that back out on the road? Yeah, I was just speaking with someone at APA about this, and I think there are definitely plans to get it back out on the road. I think we're not there yet, but one of the things we are currently working on or thinking about is how to get that available virtually. This seems to be the word of the year, right? Can we make this available virtually? And if we can, we better. So we're thinking about that right now. And I do, I think that's going to be an important step for the exhibit. But I do really hope that once once travel is allowed and once things are opened up again, that we can get it back out on the road, because I think those in-person events that happen around the exhibit are really the important part. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Fay. It's been a real pleasure talking to you. Thank you, Kim. And I hope one of these days soon, our listeners and I can visit the museum and the archives and actually see the collection.
年轻女孩和年轻女性将心理学视为一个属于她们的空间、一个热情欢迎她们的空间，以及一个能够让她们实现愿望、并在感兴趣时创造改变的空间。目前是否有计划让这个展览重新开始巡展？是的，我刚才正与美国心理协会（APA）的一位同仁讨论这件事，我认为确实有计划让它重新上路。我觉得我们现在还没完全准备好，但我们目前正在努力或思考的事情之一，是如何将其以虚拟形式呈现出来。这似乎成了年度热词，对吧？我们能把它搬到线上吗？如果可以的话，我们最好这样做。所以我们现在正在考虑这一点。而且我认为，这将是该展览迈出的重要一步。但我真的希望，一旦允许旅行、各项限制解除后，我们能让它重新开始巡展，因为我认为围绕展览举办的那些线下活动才是真正重要的部分。好的，非常感谢您今天能做客我们的节目，费博士。与您交谈非常愉快。谢谢你，金。我也希望不久之后的某一天，我们的听众和我都能够亲自去参观博物馆和档案馆，真正亲眼看到这批藏品。
I hope so, too. We would love to have you. To our listeners, you can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.w. speakingof psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我也希望如此。我们非常欢迎各位。对于我们的听众朋友，您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学聊天》往期节目，也可以在您获取播客的任何平台上收听。如果您对未来的节目有任何评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。地址是 speakingofpsychology（全部连写）@apa.org。《心理学聊天》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理协会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。